[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled automated 3d light sheet
microscopy opening new dimensions in
neuroscience
this webinar is a part of the 10th
annual neuroscience virtual conference
i am antonina salcido of labrutz and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
miltoni biotek
for more information about miltoni
biotek please visit
miltonybiotech.com
now let's get started
before we begin i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to first participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen located within the navigation bar
or from the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr amanda
burke field application scientist at
miltoni biotech inc
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
dr burke you may now begin your
presentation
want to thank everyone for joining us
today i'm excited to be given the
opportunity to discuss the power of
light sheet microscopy in the
neuroscience world and introduce you to
milton's newest light sheet microscope
ablaze
here is an outline of what i will cover
in my talk
first i will introduce you to light
cheap microscopy and how this technology
can benefit your imaging workflow
i will then provide you with an
introduction into the ultra microscope
blaze which is our new fully automated
light sheet instrument
i also want to give you a little bit of
context in terms of sample preparation
so i will give an overview of tissue
clearing
why and how we clear
and finally i will touch upon some
practical applications for 3d imaging in
the neuroscience field
so what is light sheet microscopy
light sheet microscope work as virtual
microtomes almost like a tissue scanner
with the ultramicroscope glaze
the sample is illuminated from the side
using a sheet of light the fluorescent
signal is then collected along the
vertical axis something we refer to as
the 90 degree principle
for imaging the sample is moved through
the light sheets as shown in the
animation on the right resulting in a
high resolution 3d data set
but how might this imaging technology be
important or benefit you in your imaging
workflow
if you are currently performing
traditional wide field microscopy you
are likely quite familiar with these
tissue sectioning instruments
as you know opaque tissues can be
into very thin slices something around
10 to 20 microns which ultimately makes
them translucent and it's this
translucent property that makes the
sample suitable for imaging on slides
if you're currently using this strategy
to image your samples you know how
tedious this work can be and not to
mention the damage the tissue can endure
from the suctioning blade as well as
temperature related issues
it is also common that during this
process sections can be lost and
therefore data is lost
it is true that 2d immunofluorescent
imaging is currently the most common
imaging practice
however the data obtained represents the
three-dimensional nature of the biology
in a very limited manner
in comparison renderings of a whole
intact organ can provide the full
picture
this can be observed here in these
images both samples were saying for the
vasculature marker cd31 but it is clear
that the 2d analysis on the left cannot
capture the complexity of the blood
vessels in the mouse brain as one can
appreciate of that on the 3d analysis on
the right
another common method for imaging larger
samples is confocal microscopy which
generates optical sections instead of
physical ones
can focal microscopes do this by a point
scanning mechanism across the sample
since the entire sample in the z
dimension is illuminated a pinhole in
front of the detector is necessary to
eliminate out-of-focus light
so even though you're illuminating the
entire sample volume only fluorescent
signal very close to the focal plane is
resolved and detected
in addition since much of the light from
the sample fluorescence is blocked at
this pinhole the increased resolution
you get from the optical section is at
the cost of decreased signal intensity
so to offset this drop-in signal after
the pinhole the light intensity is
detected by a sensitive detector which
basically serves to transform the light
signal into an electrical one
so while confocal microscopy is a
valuable technique for some samples and
or applications
there are a few drawbacks with regards
to acquisition acquisition speed and the
increased potential for photo bleaching
samples during an imaging session
now to compare with light sheet
microscopy the excitation and detection
paths are uncoupled and oriented
perpendicularly where the excitation
beam illuminates the sample from the
side and the detection occurs on the
vertical axis
in clear tissue the excitation beam can
propagate through the width of the
sample and therefore the light sheet
itself is creating the optical section
this means there's no requirement for
blocking out a focused light with a
pinhole or amplification of the signal
with a sensitive detector
instead light cheap microscopes are able
to acquire the entire field of view in a
single image
this gives way to much faster
acquisition times and it's a lot more
gentle to your sample in terms of photo
bleaching
now that we're all a little more
familiar with light sheet technology i'd
like to introduce miltoni's ultra
microscope light sheet platform we have
three different configurations with the
zoom body here on the bottom left
standing as our original um2 the super
plan which is the second generation um
ii on the bottom right
and then we have the ultra microscope 3
blades on top
all um systems are very easy to use and
flexible to your various imaging needs
the light sheets are optimized in these
systems to provide you with homogeneous
illumination of your sample this is
largely due to the fact that there are a
total of six sheets three on the left
and three on the right
they're all compatible with all clearing
protocols i will speak to this a little
more in the coming slides
and they can accommodate both small
samples like organoids of only a couple
millimeters or larger samples like an
entire mouse brain
and with the newest member of the
ultramicroscope family the blaze
you can image samples as large as an
entire adult mouse
i will now continue to focus on the
blaze and i really want to highlight
some innovative features that have been
incorporated into this specific um model
the blaze is fully automated light cheap
microscope which eliminates several pain
points that can occur during your
imaging sessions
with some of these features
first the automated sample release
giving you easy and fast access to your
samples with effortless sample mounting
the automated objective lens changer the
objectives live on the instrument so
there is no need for mounting and
dismounting this dramatically reduces
the potential for damaging these
objectives
and then we have the automated focusing
feature
there are no course or fine adjustment
knobs focusing in on your sample is
accomplished with just a click of the
button in the software
much of this automation is conducted
through the automated detection unit
which is controlled completely through
the software
inside the unit itself there are four
intermediate lenses providing a range of
magnifications that can be applied to
each objective
we have the multi-immersion plan
objectives this system is equipped with
a 1.1 x a 4x and a 12x objective
these lenses are specifically designed
for light sheet microscopy having the
longest working distances relative to
their numerical aperture
we have our cutting edge light sheet
optics as mentioned previously there are
a total of six light sheets two central
beams with four additional sheets
directed at an inward angle this is to
reduce shadowing effects and ultimately
resulting in homogeneous illumination of
your sample
and then we have that large automated
chamber which provides plenty of space
to either mount multiple smaller samples
for batch imaging as shown in the image
here or a very large sample something
like an entire human kidney
one feature i mentioned earlier is that
the ultra microscopes are compatible
with all clearing protocols but why do
we clear tissues and how is tissue
clearing accomplished
so let's start with the question why
in a given sample light passage is
highly impaired due to things like
reflection refraction scattering and
absorption as it encounters different
materials within the tissue
these materials are largely referring to
water proteins and lipids
and each of these molecules have a
different refractive index
the term refractive index which is a
term you will hear quite often with
regards to tissue clearing
is a numerical value that is assigned to
these different molecules and represents
the speed at which light travels through
a given material for example water has a
refractive index of 1.3
proteins around 1.5 and lipids around
1.4
this number is an expression of how much
slower light moves through a substance
compared to that of a vacuum
the higher the number the slower the
light travels in that material
so the goal of tissue clearing is to
render the tissue transparent but what
does transparency really mean
it is essentially the result of
homogenizing or matching the refractive
index of the entire sample
so the reason we clear tissue is to
remove light scattering molecules and
essentially alter the tissue composition
so that the light's behavior is
normalized as it travels through the
sample
so if you look into liver now you will
notice there are many different clearing
protocols all a little unique in their
mechanism for homogenizing the
refractive index
but here i will introduce you to three
major classes
that being the hydrophilic clearing
methods hydrogel face clearing methods
and then hydrophobic or also known as
organic clearing methods
hydrophilic clearing techniques start by
removing lipids with some form of
detergent the samples are then placed
into high concentration urea solution
and imaged in an ri matched aqueous
immersion
the resulting refractive index of
samples cleared
in this method range from about 1.38 to
1.48
so these methods are typically
quite simple and can clear tissues
rather well while also preserving
endogenous fluorescence
the main disadvantage
is the time it takes to clear samples
which with this protocol can take weeks
and it isn't always as effective as
other methods like the organic solvents
or the hydrogel-based clearing
on dense samples
hydrogel clearing methods start by
crosslinking proteins to a hydrogel
matrix for initial sample stabilization
lipids are then extracted with some
detergents
and it's this portion of the protocol
that can take quite some time when done
passively
as an alternate
and to speed up this process
active clearing can be conducted which
utilizes an electrophoresis operation
the resulting refractive index of
samples cleared with this method is
around 1.45
so people select this method um largely
because
it is non-toxic it is compatible with
immunolabeling and it also maintains
that endogenous fluorescence
some of the big disadvantages here are
typically costs associated with both the
imaging solutions
and commercial electrophoresis systems
to
ultimately achieve that active clearing
hydrophobic or also often referred to as
organic clearing methods first dehydrate
the samples using some alcohol gradient
where lipids are also extracted and
they're finally cleared in a high
refractive index organic solvent around
1.55
which is also similar to that of the
refractive index of proteins
the major advantages to organic clearing
methods is that the resulting
transparency is quite robust compared to
other methods and is relatively easy and
cost-effective workflow to adopt
they're widely used in neuroscience
really rendering those brains
quite transparent
the disadvantage here is that most of
these hydrophobic methods use toxic
chemicals and that final clearing step
which some users
like to avoid
so when it comes to tissue clearing i
hope i convey there is not a
one-size-fits-all protocol
selection of your clearing method will
depend on the tissue species your
intended application amongst other
considerations
there will always be the possibility
that you may have to adapt or modify
your protocol to achieve true refractive
index homogenized samples
not all protocols will render samples
clear enough for light sheet and
therefore may not be compatible with
this technology
but there are a lot of resources out
there including myself to help you
navigate and find the method most
suitable for your application
now that you have a general idea about
tissue clearing i want to shift gears a
little bit to antibody selection when it
comes to 3d
immunofluorescence i think it's
important to point out that the time and
effort to optimize traditional
immunolabeling conditions for 2d imaging
on slides can differ quite a bit when
applied to large samples in combination
with clearing
we will use this cerebral organoid
stained with beta tubulin iii as an
example
the left image was the result of
immunolabeling under the specifications
intended for 2d immunofluorescence this
pattern of antibody bound largely to the
perimeter of the sample is a common
result for many of those new to 3d
imaging
from this point you would have to
optimize the immunolabeling conditions
by trying to understand if this effect
is due to insufficient permeabilization
methodology
the wrong antibody concentration
or antibody incubation times
so though the image on the right was
stained with the same beta tubulin 3
antibody the conditions have already
been optimized for 3d in-text samples
where you now observe proper diffusion
of the antibody into the interior of the
organoid
so if there's an option to purchase an
antibody that has been previously
validated for 3d immunofluorescent
applications either by another lab or a
vendor taking this route can save you
both time and effort
another consideration that can also
complicate antibody optimization efforts
is if you're using an indirect method
for immunolabeling with the primary
antibody against your target which is
recognized by a secondary antibody
conjugated to that fluorescent dye
you can see the timelines outlined here
where indirect labeling systems can
increase your protocol by a week or
maybe even more
so if you have the option to go with the
primary antibody that has the
fluorescent dye directly conjugated to
it it's in your best interest not only
does this decrease the protocol timeline
and simplifies optimization efforts
because it's one antibody instead of two
but we have also seen with our direct
conjugate primary antibodies that signal
to background ratios are enhanced as you
can see in this comparison image on the
right
to address this bottleneck in tissue
clearing in 3d immunofluorescent
workflows miltoni biotech has created a
simple and streamlined solution to help
you get up and started with light sheet
imaging
first we have our max tissue clearing
kit on the left these reagents have been
developed for the hydrophobic clearing
of tissues and of an important note this
kit uses non-toxic organic solvents for
clearing and imaging
we are also providing an ever growing
list of antibodies that have been
validated for 3d immunofluorescence
some important highlights to milton's 3d
antibody portfolio is that they are all
directly conjugated to a small
photostable die
and they are recompenently engineered so
you can feel confident that you'll get
that lot to lock consistency between
experiments
our research and development department
has worked really hard to develop a full
solution to your 3d imaging needs this
includes predefined protocols that are
supplied on our web page for free for
the optimal immunostaining and clearing
of different tissue species
here is just an example of a workflow
for one of our protocols that will walk
you step by step through the
immunolabeling portion and the clearing
portion of intact mouse brains
we are now moving into the last portion
of my talk where i will review some
neuroscience-based applications using
the ultra microscope but of course
there's potential for much more than
what i will show you here
i hope that you feel free to reach out
to me i'll provide my contact
information at the end of this
presentation or you can join us at the
booth afterwards if you want to discuss
ways of enhancing your research projects
by incorporating light sheet microscopy
so a first hit on some of the most
popular areas of neuroscience research
where light sheet has proven to really
be a powerful tool
in alzheimer's and parkinson's disease
research
the 3d imaging of intact mouse brains is
allowing researchers to quantify plaques
and dopaminergic neurons with the goal
for identifying target sites and therapy
approaches
the brain that you are looking at now is
that staying for
th positive cells so those dopaminergic
neurons
so in stroke research these 3d
renderings are quite powerful tool for
evaluation of stroke affected
regions in the brain and helping to
assess therapy models of efficacy
um
the brain that you are looking at here
again it's an intact mouse brain that
was stained for cd31 that endothelial
marker
really nicely showing that vasculature
in an attempt to understand neuronal
regeneration and plasticity these 3d
images acquired from light sheet allow
researchers to quantify neuronal
plasticity using brain organoids like
this one shown here
moving up in sample size the blaze and
its large sample chamber can accommodate
3d imaging of an entire adult mouse
shown here
which provides a really nice solution
for conducting complex connectivity
mapping and analysis of neuronal
regeneration of an entire organism
this mouse here was a thigh one gfp
mouse
it was labeled for
those gfp positive neuronal structures
that you see in green
the bones and internal organs
are prominent with the pi labeling in
white and the muscles visualized by
autofluorescence background
in red
another widely used application in
neuroscience in combination with light
sheet microscopy is whole brain activity
mapping which is accomplished by
automated 3d image analysis and allen
brain atlas registration
to
essentially map those active neurons in
an intact mouse brain
the most commonly used immediate early
gene marker cfos which is used in this
study here where the researchers wanted
to look for brain regions differentially
regulated when mice explore a new
environment with or without their
whiskers
but in general this pipeline for whole
brain activity mapping has countless
possibilities in many different research
areas such as addiction stress trauma
obesity the list can go on and on
and as you can imagine our neuroscience
based reference list is ever growing if
you are interested in reviewing some of
these publications utilizing the ultra
microscope you can find this document on
our webpage
and with that i appreciate your
attention
if you have any questions i hope you
contact me my email is listed here you
can also join us in the booth for
immediate inquiries right after this
thank you
thank you dr burke for your time today
and your important research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today i'd also
like to thank our sponsor miltoni biotek
for sponsoring today's webinar
any questions submitted today and during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until march 10 2024
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with any
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you